If people say your dreams are crazy,...
...if they laugh at what you think you can do,...
...good.
Stay that way...
...because what nonbelievers fail to understand...
...is that calling a dream crazy is not an insult,...
...it's a compliment.
Don't try to be the fastest runner in your school...
...or the fastest in the world.
Be the fastest ever.
Don't picture yourself wearing OBJ's jersey.
Picture OBJ wearing yours.
Don't settle for homecoming queen or linebacker.
Do both.
Lose 120 pounds and become an Ironman after beating a brain tumor.
Don't believe you have to be like anybody to be somebody.
If you're born a refugee,...
...don't let it stop you from playing soccer for the national team at age 16.
Don't become the best basketball player on the planet.
Be bigger than basketball.
Believe in something even if it means sacrificing everything.
When they talk about the greatest team in the history of the sport,...
...make sure it's your team.
If you have only one hand, don't just watch football,...
...play it at the highest level.
And if you're a girl from Compton,...
...don't just become a tennis player,...
...become the greatest athlete ever.
Yeah, that's more like it.
So, don't ask if your dreams are crazy,...
...ask if they're crazy enough.